[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] em
[Music]
Cruise
what what did we call him now Cancun
Cancun Cruise
[Music]
Ted Cruz oh
was caught on tape there's there's
always there's always tapes with these
[__] isn't there
why why don't they just assume they're
being recorded when they're trying to I
don't know overturn the United States
government
um it appears that Jack Smith and the
special counsel and doj
has requested copies of these tapes and
again I use the word tapes like it's the
1990s and [__] right like we're like
like we got cassette tapes and a
cassette recorder of the phone calls I
don't I mean so they're they're called
tapes I guess audio recordings that's
too long tapes is much better and it it
Harkens back to Watergate right with
these um these criminal Republicans that
we have
oh my God what an idiot there's a ton of
news though it's not just it's not just
the Revelation that Ted Cruz tried to
overturn the federal government of
course he did we watched him and Josh
Hawley try to do it
and he was like he was like well this is
not a big deal he tweeted out this is
not a big deal I was saying this out
loud
so
who gives this [__] if you were saying
that we we know you were saying it out
loud we've been saying this for a long
time that you people were trying to
steal the election you were trying to
commit a coup you were trying to install
a dictator
we've been saying this
we what what have you been missing the
past two [__] years
of course we know that you were trying
to overthrow the government Ted Cruz
we know
in Josh Hawley
Ron Johnson with his oh well I didn't I
didn't uh I I didn't take the envelope
of of fraudulent electors to the vice
president it was definitely someone on
my staff
if you think Ted Cruz is the last one to
get wrapped up in this last lawmaker to
get wrapped up in this you are [__]
dreaming
and I think it's very appropriate that
these Republican criminal lawmakers are
being investigated by the special
counsel Jack Smith under turn overturn
every single one of those fascist rocks
and get rid of them cockroaches [__]
this [__]
[__] them just it's enough it's enough
just keep going Jack just keep going uh
the speaking of legal trouble holy [__]
e Gene Carroll is on the stand as we
speak I don't think there's cameras or
audio inside DM the courtroom but there
are reporters reporting what is being
said and she is on the stand
in her trying her defamation suit
against Donald Trump about the rape that
she claims happened in the 1990s and
Grandpa Poopypants is [__] posting on
front social this morning and it pissed
the judge the bright the [__] off pissed
him off
which I mean it should you can't
disparage the witness in the case our
Witnesses in the case
you can't
so and they they tried desperately to
get the names of the jury
in this case so that they can disparage
the jury and it is clear now more than
ever why the judge did not allow that
that jury to remain anything but
anonymous
because he would be posting [__]
people's names and [__]
he's he's a lunatic someone
um uh Jank Unger is on another tie raid
this morning about how Biden can't beat
Trump or some dumb [__] or well we need
a different candidate there is no other
candidate you [__] idiot we elected
Joe Biden as the president he has
decided to run he's the nominee that's
that's how it works listen honestly if
you're upset about me saying the truth
then fine whatever stay here go I don't
give a [__] but if you're mad about me
telling the truth
if you're mad about that I don't know
what to tell you I don't know what to do
for you you're J you're just not
understanding what happens in Democratic
primaries it doesn't matter what you
want it really doesn't matter it doesn't
I know it feels like oh we should get to
the side you get to decide who the
nominee is of the democratic party we
did this
in 2020 and we decided that we wanted
Joe Biden the Democratic party decided
this okay
the Democratic party decided this
and when he won he gets a chance at a
second term as the incumbent in the
Democratic party that's just how it
works
go go look at the history of the
democratic party and again if you if you
want to debate this issue let's debate
it I I mean it's not going to be much of
a debate
because it's just the simple cold hard
facts just because you don't like the
nominee or just because you don't like
the nominee's age or you don't like how
far left or far right or house center or
how independent the person is it doesn't
matter it doesn't
and I know it feels like oh well Tony
you're you're just you're glossing over
the fact that someone else should be the
nominee no I'm not someone else will be
the nominee in 2028
that's how it's gonna work
and if you and if you're if you're
ignoring those facts and how a
democratic party's primary works then
you're just you're you're just living in
a fantasy land that's all you're doing
and and it's hilarious it's hilarious
that people who are like look Joe
Biden's gonna be the nominee there's
nothing you can do to stop it he's
chosen to run those people saying oh
you're you're capitulating to Joe Biden
you're an occult [__] listen
you're the one who is believing [__]
absolute stupid ass [__]
way out there in left field [__] if
you think that Marianne Williamson is
gonna Mount any kind of campaign against
[__] Joe Biden
I even put the question to Jank this
morning on Twitter I quote tweet him I'm
like how many delegates is she gonna
have
how many
genius
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter that
a low percentage of people in this
country don't like Joe Biden's age that
doesn't matter
that that has no effect on who the
nominee is I hate to [__] tell you
that
it will in 2028 all all your worries and
all your anxiety and everything that you
want to put into a nominee
all that all that effort that you're
using to spend energy to hurt the
Democratic party and prop up fascism
right now
because that's what you're really doing
is propping up fascism
you're propping it up when you're not
attacking it when you're attacking the
the [__] duly elected United States
president that is of the democratic
party who will take the nomination if he
so chooses which he did yesterday
finally
officially
and if you're if you're not aware of
that and if you're you keep talking
about how there should be someone
different because you want someone
different guess what you're helping the
fascist you're on their team
got it
do you follow
are you following the bouncing [__]
ball
because that's the [__] cold hard
truth and if you don't like it fine
whatever be mad at me I don't give a
good goddamn you can be mad at me about
the truth all you want I really don't
give a [__]
it's it's the truth isn't for me to
[__] for me to decide
I'm I'm here to tell you what the [__]
is gonna happen I'm here to give you the
commentary and if you're over listening
to tyt right now you are a dumb
[__] that's right you need to
stop listening to that [__] trash
all of it all of it even if some of it
is good even if a son of a some of it
sounds like what I'm talking about
you're only propping up their [__]
Network to attack the Democratic nominee
who is going to run against fascism he
clearly in his ad yesterday and he
didn't watch it which if you're if
you're so been out of shape about
Trump's or excuse me Biden's age uh oh
they're about the same age folks so is
Bernie Sanders
but if you're so concerned about Joe
Biden's age
if that's your number one [__] fear
in this nation
then you're not paying attention frankly
and and if you and if you're if you keep
talking about the candidate's age which
I'm I don't even give a [__] how old
Trump is I don't give a [__]
I don't care I don't care how old Bernie
was or is or when he was trying to run I
don't give a [__]
ageism is really stupid it's really
[__] dumb it's almost as dumb as
sexism almost
it's almost as dumb as sexism that that
a man is better than a woman I mean a
woman is better than a man I'm not gonna
lie but that's just again you don't like
the [__] facts bounce [__] but
here's here's the thing is that ageism
is the same stupid [__]
I mean clearly clearly Trump and and Joe
Biden are clearly of the same age I mean
they're like two three years difference
two and a half years difference some
[__] like that right I don't know the
exact [__] number of months but it's
not far off
and clearly Joe Biden is in way better
physical health than Donald Trump
whatever dream of being I don't care
what that [__] drunk ass
sh [__] bag down in Texas Ronnie Jackson
says I don't give a [__]
Joe Biden can at least handle a ramp and
ride a bike for crying out loud
I mean I would give my left nut to be
able to ride a bike when I'm that old I
can't even really ride a bike now what
the [__]
so get the [__] over it
get listen to me get the [__] over it
it's done it's done Trump is gonna be
their nominee Biden is going to be the
Democrats nominee and I'm saying Trump
is it
that's what they got on that side folks
here's the greatest part about a trump
Biden rematch and I've said this time
and time again I'm going to say it over
and over and over and over because it's
the truth I don't know what else to tell
you
is that in a trump Biden election we
know exactly where the Biden votes are
we know exactly where the Trump votes
are we know where they are
even if the demographics change a bit we
still know where they are we know how to
win this race we know how to protect
democracy and it's Joe Biden's race to
lose
it's his race to lose this [__] crazy
ass stupid [__] that t-yd and and Jake
is trying to sell that Biden is gonna
lose because he's old the [__] are you
talking about
what are you talking about
then that means Trump's gonna lose
because he's three years difference or
two years whatever the [__] the
difference is between him
it's not gonna be anybody but Trump
folks it's just not I don't even care if
the motherfucker's sitting in a jail
cell
they're going to nominate him that's it
period
I'm sure of it barring something you
know huge like
a Big Mac gets log lodged or something
that's it
just count on it
just proceed with those set of facts
um Rob brings up a good point here he's
he talks about tyt wouldn't use age
argument if it was Bernie running well
yesterday on air I said that a hundred
percent Bernie Sanders is going to
endorse Joe Biden
I said that
and hours later he did because Bernie
Sanders is not going to stand in the way
here he's just not
Bernie Sanders has no he he has no
ability to primary an incumbent
president he knows that Bernie Sanders
is smart enough to know how it works
Bernie Sanders got taken by surprise in
2016 when his message resonated with
young people and he gathered up a very a
very sizable Coalition but he wasn't
part of the democratic party he was
never a member of the democratic party
what what made him think that super
delegates were gonna back an independent
and not the [__] Democrat it's really
bone-headed stuff that you people don't
understand how this works they're not
gonna pick someone outside the party
it's not gonna happen just like in 2020
when everyone thought Bernie was going
to win and Joe Biden went to South
Carolina with with representative
clyburn's endorsement it set off a
firestorm of the democratic party going
yes Joe Biden's the one that can beat
Donald Trump and they chose the nominee
that could beat Trump and he can do it
again he'll he could do it 10 times in a
row you stupid bastards
you people out there Downing Joe Biden
would beat Donald Trump every single
time 10 times in a row if he had to
foreign
and the reason why is because America is
sick and tired of the [__] dumpster
fire they're [__] sick and tired of
it
and if you don't believe me just look
what's happening in some of these State
houses as these state legislators are
trying to pass these stupid [__]
hateful bills
hating on women hating hating on the
lgbtq community hating on children
hating on education hating on [__]
books and libraries are you [__]
kidding me Americans don't want to be
told what the [__] they're gonna do and
that's all this party the Republican
party wants to do
so listen to me when I say this to the
pro-democracy Coalition out there if you
have any inkling inside of you
that Joe Biden Joe Biden is not the
nominee or can't be the nominee or is
not going to win or whatever the [__]
whatever doubt you have and I'm not
saying you shouldn't have doubt but
whatever doubt you have rested aside I'm
telling you this is this this is the
situation that the Democratic party
wants and democracy wants and needs the
incumbent Democratic president running
on the ticket because that's what's
gonna happen and you can't stop it tyt
can't stop it the voters in the
Democratic party can't stop it that's
what happens when you elect a Democratic
president that's what happens
I don't I don't I don't know how else to
say
those words and to give you the facts
and again when tyt especially Jank over
there who runs dyt says stupid [__] like
he's saying and tweet stupid [__] like
he's tweeting
he's only sowing self-defeetism
inside the pro-democracy coalition
and he's making it so that he can make
it appear that Biden is weak
and that helps his narrative and helps
him gain an audience and keep his
audience and keep him giving him money
that's what it is
I mean lies lies and and Sensations sell
really well
on commentary they really do they really
do and this sensationalism that oh my
God Joe Biden's Joe Biden's old and he's
not going to be able to beat Trump who's
just as old
[Music]
[__] out of here with that nonsense
you know the one thing that Americans
will appreciate when it comes to the
election next year
I'm telling you I'm I'm gonna give you
I'm going to clue you in on this
because it is going to be an absolute
mess next year this is going to be a
mess Republicans I mean Jesus Christ
Kevin McCarthy there's another piece of
news Kevin McCarthy can't even get a
[__] budget pass he can't even get
his caucus oh big surprise big surprise
Kevin McCarthy can't whip his caucus no
[__] Sherlock because it ain't his
caucus he's not the speaker
this is a complicated folks this isn't
I I I know I know people want to and
commentators news networks
and other [__] people out there
in in the space of politics want to make
it complicated so that oh man the
average American can't understand this
so I'm gonna build commentary that makes
it so complicated and so hard to
understand it's not it really is [__]
simple it's simple [__]
you most most of the audience 99.9 of
the audience here is average working
middle class Americans
and you understand it you get it
that's why you come here to get that
cathartic release
of Truth
and re just real raw politics no [__]
Thrills no data no polls
no [__] weird ass theories about how
somehow the incumbent Democratic
president is going to lose the general
election against someone who's going to
be up against who knows how many dozen
felony charges in States and the federal
and doj who knows
who knows at this point and who knows
who who else will be roped in in his
orbit
with all the trials that are going on
the Eugene trial it's day two of the
gene aging Carroll trial today she's on
the stand calling Donald Trump a rapist
in open court
which I mean I guess we'll find out what
the jury thinks in that
but you also had this uh what's her name
Abigail whatever from Fox News
this [__] going on
Tucker's gone
Cruz is calling and plotting with the
Fox News anchors
a fake commission to overturn the
election
you think this isn't going to be a
[__] dumpster fire and folks the
dumpster fire isn't going to be on the
Democratic side
you're gonna have to that's that's the
Stark difference
the choices is going to be democracy
level handed democracy with Democrats
who are serious about policy serious
about Administration serious about the
executive branch serious about
government in general and then the
absolute [__] trumpster dumpster fire
over here
authoritarianism
you're going to want them to be of the
authoritarians
I I want to give you a lot of confidence
here because folks that's that's where
we're headed that's why that's why tyt
is and Jank is a little upset
that's a little it's It's upsetting to
them and the reason why is because the
same stupid [__] when I attack them and
people's like oh Tony well you know that
they attack the other side you know that
they hold Democrats accountable well
they're supposed to be on the left and
I'm holding them accountable so shut the
[__] up okay
get the [__] over it just just because
just because they're bad for democracy
but but they say some of the same [__]
or have some of the same line of
thinking I do doesn't mean that I'm not
gonna [__] call them out when they're
bad for democracy because they are
they're horrible they're horrible for
democracy it's a horrible institution
over there it may not have started that
way but I'll tell you I've played the
clip on here where where Jank said that
Barack Obama was a republican he's he's
never been on our side folks
and anyone out there who listens to that
garbage him over there or or follows his
tweets or likes his tweets or or thinks
he's a brilliant [__]
you've been duped
because he's not he's not brilliant he's
the opposition to the Democrats that's
what he is he's opposition to
pro-democracy Coalition that's what he's
doing
so that's why I call him out that's why
I I [__] bring it up
because we're gonna have to get our
house in order in the next six eight
months here
we're gonna have to get it in order
and the reason why is because we have to
build this coalition to pile these
[__] under mountains of votes
I'm very positive and very
I'm very optimistic about the the
presidential election in 2024. very
optimistic
but we have House Seats to win we have
Senate seats to win we have state
legislators to win
we can rent we can win some governor's
races folks this is important [__]
I don't I don't know if you you've
noticed like in Tennessee or or Montana
or some of these others Texas Florida
what these [__] state legislators in
these State houses are doing
but I'm telling you and these Governors
like DeSantis and some of these others
of course DeSantis has already won but
we have some governor's races coming
I'm telling you the fight the fight is
going to be all the way down the ballot
and if we can paint the entire
Republican ballot it's a bunch of
[__] whack-a-doos who aren't going to
govern are only going to take your
rights away Americans are going to make
considerations here
and the consideration is going to be do
I keep voting with my affiliation or is
my affiliation just not worth it anymore
and that's what we have to convince them
of that's why we have to keep yelling
and screaming into the microphone
I I and again I only have one microphone
you got thousands
but this is super important and I know
it's like oh Tony you're just painting a
broad brush that all democrats should be
elected yeah that's exactly what I'm
doing I mean I I hate I hate to give you
the realization that the Republican
party is absolutely dead and it's only
lifeblood is fascism but if you haven't
been paying attention
they're wanting to take your [__]
rights away from you and they are
they are actively doing it
right now as we speak as we sit here
there are Republicans plotting somewhere
to take away people's rights in this
country
so leave it up to you I guess I don't
know
that was one of the things that James
said I think it was yesterday or day
before he hasn't he hasn't met one one
voter that wants you but that wants Joe
Biden to be the nominee yeah
oh man you need to Puck your head out of
your ass Jank you seriously need to get
out more
I don't know just look in your [__]
comments every once in a while Jesus
Christ go go to my quote tweets of your
tweets and then look at those comments
and you'll see that there's plenty of
[__] out there that are that
are 100 excited of having a level-headed
president and a very effective a very
effective executive
rather you think that he goes far enough
on your on your idea of what policy
should be or not fine whatever
but you're you're gonna you're gonna
you're gonna run against a lot of
opposition here when it comes to the
2024 general election and the reason why
is because of people like me I'm not
gonna shut up I'm not gonna stop it's
it's not I'm not gonna quit saying what
I'm saying
it's it's not gonna happen
and if someone tries to stop me then
I'll just go more independent someone
tells me to shut up I'll just be more
independent I'll just cut all my ties if
I have to with whatever platform I need
to because I'll tell you one thing
I'll tell you one thing the audience
here is a loyal audience and they get
they get the truth
you guys get it you guys understand it
it's it's not hard it's not difficult
to form a basic narrative and a basic
truth
of what our institution of government
and democracy is about it's not that
difficult to sell it to folks it really
isn't
so keep on your stupid ageism [__] keep
on your stupid help and Trump out [__]
keep keep going at it if you want to but
I'm I'm not going to play that game and
I'm gonna call you out when you're doing
it especially in the next six or eight
months in the lead up to the primaries
for the Republicans because that's the
actual race that's the actual election
cycle that we're going to be in soon is
a Republican primary and I'm hoping I'm
hoping that there's some Challengers
that get in that give Grandpa a run for
his money just like e Gene Carroll is
giving Grandpa poopy pants a run for his
money this morning in the E Gene Carroll
trial I think it's just gonna be me for
most of the day
Gabe Sanchez is out with an appointment
um so you got me today for two hours
so sit back and relax because we're
gonna go at it if you're not subscribed
to the Tony Michaels podcast what the
hell are you doing with your life you
need to go ahead and subscribe right now
it's free it's free it doesn't cost you
a single nickel to watch this show every
single weekday Monday through Friday
noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific for
two full hours also download every
single episode
this is one big ask I'll ask of the
audience if you can go download the
audio version every day that would be
great that would be great that would
help us out a lot here on the Tony
Michaels podcast so go download it on
Apple Spotify Google make sure to leave
us a good review on whatever directory
you download it on also follow us on
Facebook if you're not already at the
Tony Michaels hey facebookers out there
go to at the Tony Michaels you may be
watching this broadcast on Facebook but
you may not be following me you need to
be
also if you got an Amazon Prime account
you can link it to your Twitch account
you twitch Watchers out there I'm trying
to get the twitch subscribers up too
so we've got let me see let me check it
here let me check it here let me see
again I got my uh
get my
Command Center going here
yes so we're we're almost to 900
subscribers I'd like to get to a
thousand subscribers over there on on
Twitch so even if you don't have an
Amazon Prime account go follow us on
Twitch get our follower account up over
there but if you do have an Amazon Prime
account what you can do is you can link
your Amazon Prime account to the Twitch
account
and you get one free subscription with
your Twitch account
are your Amazon Prime account excuse me
and you can give that to me the Tony
Michaels podcast in twitch and I get a
few dollars
of Amazon's money every month now you
have to renew it each month like right
now Robin mama bird
of seven over there on on Twitch she
re-subscribed for one month and this is
her fourth month subscribing
um black eye Dilly subscribed yesterday
thank you caretaker 909 has been
subscribed for four months they renewed
their subscription yesterday and DJ Sam
subscribed yesterday with their Prime
account uh so did a few others so go
over
to Twitch link your Amazon Prime account
give us a few dollars of Amazon's money
for free it doesn't cost you anything to
do this if you have an Amazon Prime
account and if you known Amazon Prime
account try twitch Out Try It Out
download the app follow us over there
let's get to a thousand followers over
there
I want I want to try to get as many
followers as we can on as many platforms
um just anywhere and everywhere we can I
wanna I wanna make sure to increase our
reach here as we get into the 2024 uh
cycle here so everyone stick around you
just got me today we'll be right back
right after this
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker Convoy
there's Tammy by the time we reach DC
White was 50 strong in number some
patriots ran out of gas along the way
we got plenty of Slim Jims skull
near run out of Natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
Circle the city again years
Bob
dear Bob I'm fixing to send you some
more of them Doritos you like the red
bag now they lived love and blue one in
your absence I discovered a rash on my
neck and no it ain't no hickey and I
even seen my cousin Brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
yours Tammy
[Music]
[__] them [__] em [__] em [__] em
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome back to the Joe it's hump day
Wednesday April 26th you're watching
Tony Michaels podcast or listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast here on
YouTube Twitter or twitch
maybe you downloaded the audio from
Apple Spotify or Google but we are here
every single weekday for two full hours
noon Eastern 11 Central live live is
that radio in that for you I know I
think that's pretty good let's do uh
let's do some shoot this [__] here why
not it's just me today so let's shoot
some [__] you guys want to ask me some
questions you're welcome to ask any
questions that you want I'll try to get
to as many as I can here
um in the chat so go ahead and start
putting your questions if you will put a
question mark in front of the question
as well so I can find it easier see
here's the thing like my my my comment
feed is from two Facebook pages two
YouTube Pages the twitch page so there's
like four it's a lot it's a lot and it's
really fast
so I gotta I gotta like slow it down
sometimes to find your to find your
questions and to find comments that's
kind of what happened yesterday with the
um the mix-up with uh Brendan and
Brendan's out there we love you Brendan
we love you we love you we're glad
you're here every single day
um so like oh here we go here we go
um ellipse there on Facebook says
question when did you start your podcast
it was over two years ago
I told the story a couple times if you
join the patreon we do an ask me
anything
um and you can actually see some of
those old ones and I talk about like how
it came to be how I got to have the bond
guest and that sort of thing um it
started with Tick Tock but we started
almost two years ago and we actually
just used used to do once a week but
then when Gabe Sanchez came on executive
producer and co-host it was about two
months after
um he came on we started doing every
single day
um so it's been a long time this is
episode
382. holy [__] 382 episodes of the
podcast so thank you for the question uh
did it it do who else has got a question
here who else wants to shoot the [__]
well anything that Teresa asked on
Facebook will anything happen to cooing
Cruz or Cancun Crews or cancoo Crews I
think that's Cancun Cruise I think
that's what I'm gonna call it I think
that's what I'm gonna land on here
Cancun Cruise
um I don't know I mean honestly
um if anything's if anyone is going to
do anything about
the
the situation between Fox News and any
of these lawmakers because that's the
difference like if it was um let's say
if it was just some nobody or some no
name that really wasn't involved in the
administration or wasn't involved in I
don't know certifying the election in
the senate or the house
I mean Ted Cruz had something at stake
here so whether it's criminal not I
don't I mean I guess Jack Smith and a
grand jury is going to decide that right
so we'll see about that but I I think I
think it's in the appropriate hands of
Jack Smith and the special counsel and
the grand jury is looking and not just
cancoo Crews but also other lawmakers
possibly Josh Hawley definitely Scott
Perry of Pennsylvania the representative
Pennsylvania possibly Jim Jordan at this
point it seems like Jim Jordan is
terrified Matt Gantz Marjorie Taylor
green I've got some I got some tape of
Matt gets and Marjorie Taylor green here
in just a bit that I want to show you
let's see who else
two owls oh here's another one
um what did I do before I started this
show
um nothing I didn't exist I just I came
out of thin air no I'm just kidding um I
mean I I did a lot of things in my life
I've had a lot of careers but mostly in
sales mostly in sales let's see did it
do I think Brian Kemp in Georgia uh
techno lawyer says here uh we'll veto
the [__] prosecutorial oversight
bill that they passed if he doesn't I
worry they'll fire Willis I mean I don't
actually think that it's gonna matter
much I mean there's if they're trying to
stop the freight train of a criminal
grand jury in Fulton County I think
they're barking up the wrong tree really
honestly I mean obviously they're going
to be a bunch of [__] nincompoop
Nazis and they're gonna try to stop it
at any accountability for Republicans
anywhere they can even if they hate each
other like Brian can't [__] hates
Trump
and I don't know if you saw this but it
appear it appears that the grand jury is
coming to a tail end of criminal charges
because Fannie Willis in Georgia has
given law enforcement
a heads up and a letter saying hey I'm
going to announce between this time and
this time something significant and you
might want to be ready so which only
indicates that it's Trump that's going
to have an announcement against his ass
I mean no no one law enforcement isn't
going to ramp up and get all excited
because Rudy Giuliani is [__]
indicted in Georgia folks what what
megalodites do you know that are going
to go down to Georgia and cause a
problem because Sydney Powell the Kraken
is indicted or some no-name state
legislators in Georgia who were part of
the uh the fraudulent elector scheme
come on the only the reason why vanny
Willis is [__] giving this this
warning to law enforcement is because
someone major at the top is doing it
that's that's what it is
um D.A on uh YouTube says how did how
how you meet Gabe how did I meet Gabe on
Twitter that's how I saw his videos I I
sent him a message say hey man come on
the show you can actually go watch that
episode if you if you down or if you go
to the Tony Michaels podcast on YouTube
don't forget to subscribe and you can
find that interview with Gabe Sanchez
you can find it on the YouTube channel
you can find it the interview that I did
with him before he was the co-host
um because at the time and me and him
have talked about this since then
at the time he was doing the parody and
satire videos that you guys love so much
and I I was gonna have him on the show
and the the subject matter was his
parody and satire dead as Maga and Trump
killed parody and satire so you go watch
that interview if you want
um
so you can go watch that one
let's see yeah someone says I want to
see that one that's big stuff over on
Twitch yeah it's on there
it's on there
I think you probably just search uh Gabe
Sanchez interview I would imagine on the
channel
I would say that's the case or let me
see I think it might be in a playlist
somewhere hang on let me find this let
me let me figure this out for you let's
see playlist
um it might be in the uh if you go to
the playlist tab guest interviews
and it's probably
it's probably in there
um let's see
no no it's not in that one maybe it's in
the um the the playlist
um Gabe Sanchez appearances that might
be it too
that could be it that could be it I
don't know it's on there somewhere
though yes
no no it's not in there too okay I'll
make you a deal I'll make you a deal
I'll find the video and I'll put it
somewhere for you guys to sign find it
is that not fair enough let me see if
you search I don't know
I'll find the link and I'll post it how
does that sound
fair enough okay let's see we got
another question let's shoot some more
[__] here
someone says they're searching now
this is searching Now searching now
um how did I get involved with Midas
Touch
uh well it's kind of a simple story
actually I just emailed Ben mizellis and
emailed me back and he came on the show
that's right I interviewed Ben myzealous
uh on the show here too so you can go
find that interview that was uh in 2020.
I believe
I think so it was in 2020 uh when I did
that interview no 21 2021 is when I did
that interview with Ben MineZ Ellis
so 2021 uh Ben myzealous was on the show
and that's that's how we got connected
and uh we stayed pretty close and and he
he he enjoys how I do the show I think
uh he thinks it's very unique there's no
one else on the left who does commentary
like I do it so
um
how many magas do you do
do you think still support Trump Vicki
ask on YouTube I mean I I say it all the
time I think it's about 10 or 12 percent
it's a large number of people
who are still a cultists like really
part of the cult now he'll he'll he'll
get 25 percent
of the country easily possibly up to 30
right
I mean it's a possibility that he'll
receive that in votes now his votes
total is going to go down
um since 2020 he's not going to win any
more votes than he won he'll lose votes
and Biden will gain a heftier margin and
depending on how these criminal uh
trials and these criminal problems that
he has goes and how this Fox News thing
goes have the January 6 who's tied into
it the Georgia if there's indictments
out of Georgia what it looks like what
the charges are I mean it's it's
possible it's possible that Joe Biden
could level a 10 to 15 million point
margin
um vote margin on him and the popular
vote uh but you know that doesn't really
matter in our country it should but it
doesn't but when Joe Biden's winning by
that much of a margin in the popular
vote he's just Biden Biden's not going
to be overcome by Trump and the other
reason why is because we did our work in
2022. you have to remember every
election [__] matters it's not just
the no last one in the next one every
every one of them matters 2020 matters
in this space because it'll be Biden and
and Trump right that election matters
the data in that election matters
because it's the same essential match-up
okay now
the 2022 election matters and we made
sure to secure a backstop a safety
Democratic backstop and I don't mean
Democratic party I mean democracy for
democracy when when we made sure that
Pennsylvania Michigan Wisconsin and
Arizona we did not give the extremist
Maga election deniers the fascist
treasonous pieces of [__] the
governorship the attorney general or the
Secretary of State spots in those States
that's the most important thing that you
have to remember is their plan listen to
me when I tell you this and you can go
listen to the cleta Mitchell uh tape
she's she's projecting this [__] right
out in the open in front of Republicans
saying hey we're gonna lose if we don't
steal this election is basically what
she's saying and their plan to steal the
election in 2024 was Pennsylvania
Michigan Wisconsin and Arizona that was
their plan to steal it their plan was to
have the governors the attorney generals
and the Secretary of States to Railroad
the voters in those states to give the
electors to Trump
so
um there's a there's a question on up
wire
um
when will The
gqp Rake steppers be exposed for the
frauds they are they're all ready I
expose them every day I mean if they if
you're looking if you're looking to get
them exposed just come here
I mean that's that's the whole point of
the show right I mean it really is it's
it's the whole point of the show is to
expose these [__] now I I
essentially I I have the best audience
in the world we got a very loyal
audience who watches the entire show
from front to back almost every single
day and it's five days a week there
there's no there's no other I I I think
Hal doesn't Hal do five or five days a
week
um he doesn't do the same exact times
though Hal does a little different we
have a lot of sparklers here and welcome
to any sparklers that come Hal is
probably the closest
and and maybe Richard or Jetta is
probably the closest to my commentary
that's probably the closest you're gonna
get
um to what my commentary is
um and and what the show is and how it
works it's probably the closest that
you'll get is is Hal Sparks and Richard
ojetta
um but you're not gonna and but I don't
think I don't know does does the major
do a show five days a week maybe I
should have the major on at some point I
like I like to get how on but our our
times can conflict a lot of times
and um Hal's a good friend of mine we're
friends we've talked we're we're we're
we're in good standing me and Hal
um but we just we're doing our own shows
and that's okay there's nothing wrong
with that there's nothing wrong with
each commentator independently doing
their own show their own schedule and
and keeping Their audience and in in
that space because there's plenty of
there's plenty of audience to be shared
around right well we don't have to fight
over audience
um
um so but Deb but here's the uh here's
here's the thing
is is that we have to get our
microphones bigger and that's it's up to
you to do that because again we're just
one microphone me how and whoever else
um you're thousands of them uh Kevin on
Facebook says Coke or Pepsi
it depends
all right now I don't know if people
know this but McDonald's their Coke
formula is different
then the fountain Coke formula and
McDonald's is different than the coke
formula at other places
but I have to say I I prefer Pepsi and
I'm a Pepsi guy and I don't know what to
tell you but I love I love uh McDonald's
fries and their Coke I'm not gonna lie
what my favorite
one of my favorite I don't know just um
it just is and has been
let's see here
um doesn't Richard Ojeda work on tyt see
that's what I'm saying right when I say
tyt right I'm not disparaging every
single personality that is over on tyt
and I'm not disparaging every single
comment that's on tyt what I'm
disparaging is Jank
and the overall arcing commentary of tyt
and what he's trying to do over there
and frankly if you watched uh some of
the uh some of the the videos of Anna
and Jake lately they've abandoned some
of their commentators over there because
their commentators have spoke out
against their number one against a
little bit of the turftism
because they've turned into turfs
because it's a it's it's gonna kind of
try to help them make money
but I'm telling you I'm telling you tyt
is toxic and you can tell Richard oh
Jedi said that I'll have Richard on and
tell him that to his face and he's
worked with tyt for a long time
I believe he's done commentary and
content for him for a long time
so but you know what I don't give a [__]
I I like the major but I'll speak out
against tyt if I want to and you know
what if the major doesn't like it he can
speak out against me I'll hold no
personal grudge against him it's it it's
definitely a politics and elections
thing
but I don't think you'll do that
um
who do I see running against uh Parsons
oh you're asking a Missouri election
question uh in 2024 Parsons is not
running in 2024. by the way
he's not
he won't be
um I mean it's it's gonna be Mike Kehoe
probably is going to be the lieutenant
governor right now is probably going to
step in his place Mike Keo is leveled up
attacks in the last few days against Joe
Biden which would indicate that he's
interested in some sort of run as
Missouri governor but Parsons isn't
going to run he took greitens after
greitens had to step away in his first
term and he he won his second term in
2020 so
um it's greitens isn't gonna or I mean
excuse me Parsons yeah isn't it's not
gonna it's not gonna be running against
anyone so he won't be on a ticket
that's just a little bit of Missouri
politics
why aren't you part of Midas Touch
Network already
I am but I isn't
um and you know Midas Touch has done a
lot for me they're great we're
broadcasting on their Facebook page
right now and that's where we broadcast
is on their Facebook page
um but I'm too
how do I say this
my mouth does not allow me to be on
someone else's YouTube channel let's
just say that that's why you see Clips
over me over there on Midas touches uh
Network every once while now I did do
their I did their um the January 6th
select coverage me and Gabe produce that
for them
um I was the host on every single
hearing if some people a lot of people
that's how you found me
was over there
um and and I had a job to do I had to be
a host over there for the select
committee uh to do a panel
um so it wasn't my show it wasn't my
show but this this is my show and I get
creative control over my show and the
reason why I'm on my channel is so that
I have my creative control over the show
um and and you know some people do some
people don't agree with the with the
content format that I have but I believe
in it I believe that long term that this
is the format that will sustain a
pro-democracy coalition and I think
people will follow I really do think
people will follow this format a longer
format not a short format meaning you're
always going to have your your clips
and your little shorts or reels uh
depending on which social media platform
you're on because when you're on social
media you want those little quips right
as you're thumbing through social media
but if if you're sitting around and you
want to listen to commentary of the news
that it happened up until that point
you're going to want to listen to a long
form show this is why Fox News exists
this is why you see CNN MSNBC exists
that's why talk radio exists folks and
it's not just it's not just because
um
of what people are saying it's how
they're saying it it's how it's being
presented it's how the commentary is
formatted because when you're talking
about
um people's attention it's not about
what you're saying it's about how you're
saying it first and then what you're
saying is second right so
um the reason why I'm not full-fledged
on the Midas Network like I don't have
my show on their YouTube channel is
because of my mouth it really is I get
banned it happens
ah
it happens what am I gonna do
but I love the brothers the brothers are
good friends of mine
um and they've they've helped me a lot
um throughout my journey here in this
space
and I think they know that I'm I'm gonna
be a big hit I think that's you know I
think that you know not Pat myself on
the back or anything but I think they
know I'm gonna be a big kid
uh
let's see what else do we have here
do we have any more we got about seven
minutes left here in this half hour
we're gonna come to the top of the hour
hmm
someone said uh Richard chill Richard or
Jetta is that Ethan at 8pm
so that's why we don't we don't cross
over because he's at night
and I I actually believe
um that this time slot the noon eastern
time slot is the most effective time
slot that's the other reason
why I think our show will be um
it will be successful because it's the
most important time slot of the day
um
let's see okay I've already been there
let's see if we got any more questions
here
is there a true identity for democracy
or is everyone for themselves not for
for them
hour for everyone
are out for everyone
I I think I I think I know what you're
saying here the question is is there a
true identity for democracy
um not exactly I mean you know this is
why the the argument we're not a
democracy we're we're a republic exists
is because some people's idea of
democracy is different but definitions
and mean something and words and
definition of words definitely mean
something and a constitutional
representative Republic is at 100
percent ours is a democracy rather they
like it or not I mean when someone tells
you that their definition of democracy
and they're not nailing the head with
the hammer they probably don't like
democracy because it's hard it's hard
for people to define democracy that
don't like it and the reason why is
because most of the things that
democracy promotes Equity equality
rights Liberty Freedom they don't like
they don't want people to have Liberty
they don't want people to have rights
and freedoms to choose what they want
they want to be able to choose it for
them that's this whole Christian
nationalism thing
um I've got a video to show you on that
today as well so
um you know that's why I believe that
our show here is going to be truly
affected because it is a it is a new
brand it has been a long time since
there's been a brand of liberalism like
it has here on this show
um it just it just is
um I I believe liberalism is the
strength of our country of our democracy
of freedom and liberty and that's just
how that's my [__] View and that's my
identity of democracy and that's the one
I'm selling here the narrative and the
messaging and I think if we can all get
on board with the pro-democracy
Coalition we can do a lot of things now
for equity and equality in this country
what else do we have do you guys like
when I do the ditties I used to do that
a lot when I was um
doing the [__] list Roundup the shitless
Roundup used to only be on Twitch
and I would just surf Twitter that's
where the Surf's Up [__] comes
from at the end of the show I've gotten
that question a lot like where does that
come from because I was surfing Twitter
on the [__] list Roundup and then at the
end of it I would say Surf's Up
[__] so that's where the Surf's
Up comes from if you're wanting to know
I know you didn't ask that question but
I get that question a lot let's see
this ain't a question but Rob I'm with
you CNN is trash so the other day I took
a lot of Fire
for what I said about Don Lemon and and
um maybe I'll maybe I'll go through that
a little bit today since I'm on my own
he um apparently the interview he did
with vivec and I've I've been in a
Twitter space with the Vic he's of the
fraud is what Vivek is and apparently
it's the interview
um with Vivek that Don Lemon did when he
was pushing him on civil rights and what
what Civil Rights was and what it wasn't
and history and what history is and what
history wasn't
um it's is apparently the clip they got
that was the straw that broke the
camel's back with Don Lemon and I I
actually I'm I'm kind of on Don lemon's
that side In that clip I actually think
Don could have done a better job
of Smashing up the back's argument but I
think that's what's wrong that's what's
wrong
with the mainstream media is they're not
liberal enough and they don't lean in
and tell these [__] [__]
you're a line sack of [__] good enough I
just don't think they do that that's why
I'm here to do it every day so
um when when I was attacking Don Lemon
and saying that he's not that great he's
not he's not he was the best talent that
CNN has well that's not saying much
folks it really isn't it really isn't it
Rosebud says you found Tony Michaels
podcast because of minus touch yes
and they have done a wonderful job in
helping promote the show here and
promote my personality
as much as you would love it or love to
hate it I don't know
so thank you to the my zealous Brothers
over there minus touch let's see
what else do we have what else do we
have
where are we at here do we have any more
questions and we got a few more minutes
so I can um
who hosted the January 6th hearings that
was me Bill that was me I don't know if
you're asking or if you're telling in
that but it was I'm the one who hosted
uh all the January 6 select coverage on
Midas touch that was aired across their
Network on Facebook twitch and their
YouTube channel we had guests like uh
David Bender
um Jessica Denson Michael Cohen uh we
had Ron Reagan uh let's see Rachel
bittacoffer was on Hal was on one panel
I believe I think yeah how it was on one
panel let's see who else did we have
um of course we had the my zealous
Brothers we have Gabe Sanchez we had
Texas Paul uh popoc Karen agnifical
agnifolo KFA was on the the legal AF
team was always on
um let's see who else do we have
I'm trying to think there's a lot of
folks that we had on as guests
um for for the commentary oh uh lee
McGowan politics girl she was she was on
uh she was she was part of the panel a
few times when she was available so it
was it was a great time it was a great
time I think I think we had um Harry
Littman on once
uh Harry's uh talking feds and he's a
contributor for MSM illegal contributor
for MSNBC
um so we had Harry on once I'm trying to
think who else we had on it was a lot of
coverage it was a lot of hours
um I know
um Kevin says you need to be radio Kevin
I listen
Kevin on Facebook says I should be on
radio the problem is is the FCC whoa let
me be on the radio I use the f word too
much I curse too much
and I've been told this a lot
like I've been I got I've gotten phone
calls from people you would know for
people yeah I'm not going to say their
names but people you would know they
would say hey if you just if you just
ease up on the cursing
if you just eased up on the cursing you
could be syndicated everywhere
and I can do a show without cursing it's
a possibility but would you want that
would you listen to me do a show without
cursing now that you've heard how good I
am at it would it be something that you
would I don't know watch two hours a day
Tony Michaels without saying the F word
see I can do commentary without without
cursing it is possible
it's just not something I really like to
do
[Laughter]
oh boy okay any more questions we're
running out of time here
um
anyone else anyone someone says don't
change your style yeah I'm not I'm not
gonna go anywhere
I'm not gonna go anywhere
this is my style this is what it's gonna
be like this is how it's gonna work all
right you're listening to it right here
at the Tony Michaels podcast let's see
let's see if we get one more question I
want to do one more question let's see
if I can find one
um what do I think was air America's
downfall their funding the person who
funded air America was a fraud they fell
for it I mean air America was good like
Al Franken I know David Bender was part
of air America when it started
um so it wasn't it wasn't that air
America wasn't good it was just the
financing uh was bogus and and they got
they got duped and and it wasn't their
fault just that's just what happened
it's just what happened so
oh yeah some people are saying Series XM
sxm
um I've been told I should pitch to XX
um but I don't know that I'd fit on
their Progressive network over there I
don't know if I'd fit very well I don't
I don't identify as a progressive I'm a
liberal not a progressive I mean it's
Progressive is just a cute way of saying
I don't want to tell you I'm a liberal
[__] that [__] I'm a liberal I mean
sxm if you want I'll open my own station
over there and I'll bring my heat three
hours a day we'll do three hours a day
over in sxm I mean you gotta simulcast
it I'm not gonna I'm not gonna make sure
people aren't gonna get this show for
free but I'll tell you I'll tell you
that I would try to find some more uh
guns blazins type people to put on a
channel like that
I would I would I would all right
everyone stick around where I'm gonna
come back I'm gonna take a quick break
I need a drink of water I'm gonna take a
quick break and when we come back we'll
shoot this [__] I'm gonna show you some
clips
um from today's stories today's news
we're going to go through the shitless
Roundup don't go anywhere we'll be right
back right after this
we'll be right back Mark
60 seconds this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the Show Christina says
she listens to progression
and I would be fine over there yeah I
listen to Progressive too I listen to
you uh Stephanie every once in a while
in the morning someone asked me out the
other day do I listen to other shows and
other commentary and I I try not to
ahead of my commentary so what I mean by
that is I try not to listen to a lot of
commentary before the show
um I'll listen to it in the afternoon
sometimes and in the evenings but I I
don't I don't want to pollute my
commentary and it's not that I don't
think that their commentary is good or
bad I just don't want their commentary
to reflect mine
if that makes sense I'm trying to
develop a commentary that's fresh for
you guys at noon Eastern uh during the
day so if I listen to Stephanie in the
morning I have to be very careful
because I don't I don't want it to
pollute my show or pollute the
commentary that you get from my show
take it very seriously
it's very serious stuff over here at the
Tony Michaels podcast of what the actual
stories and what the commentary is that
comes out of here and and the things
that I try to show you
um that's why it's important when I take
time to bash on tyt there's a reason for
it
there's a [__] reason for it they're
they're going to be a threat if we don't
smash this [__] folks and I mean that
narrative that defeatist narrative that
oh Joe Biden's gonna lose
well that's gonna that's gonna equate to
losing of votes and we can't afford it
with with the way our democracy stands
right now we just can't afford that kind
of nonsense
because them them saying that oh our
democracy is on the ropes and we need to
choose a candidate that's going to be
good for our democracy not not someone
like Joe Biden get the [__] out of here
man Joe Biden is going to be the nominee
whether you like it or not that's the
process that's how it works it's just
how it [__] works and if you don't
like how it works fine whatever that
that's fine if you don't like how it
works but don't act like it works a
different way don't lie don't [__]
people to think that Marianne Williamson
can mount any kind of a campaign against
Joe Biden to win enough delegates to win
at the Democratic National Convention in
Chicago next summer you're a dumb
[__] if you if you believe any
of that garbage if you believe anything
that Unger is saying about Joe Biden and
how he he should be challenged you are
brainwashed by Jank and tyt that's just
the cold hard fact you are tyt cult
member I hate to tell you this
but they're selling you [__] that just
ain't true that's not real it's not
coupled to reality at all the same way
as the election Denial in 2020. the
people running around believing the
elections was stolen with no evidence is
stupid it's dumb ridiculous stuff and
it's dumb ridiculous stuff to not know
exactly how the Democratic primary is
going to be laid out for an incumbent
president
who won by eight million votes you
[__] he won by eight million a
margin of 8 million votes
it's not complicated to understand why
Joe Biden gets to pick if he's going to
be the nominee or not he's a sitting
president he's the head of the
Democratic Party
that the Democratic party's process for
an incumbent president basically
guarantees with super delegates
that the president incoming president if
if they decide as much that they're
going to be the nominee and run for
president that they will be
that's how it that's how it works
so if you're selling anything else
you're selling lies that's how I see it
uh so here's Christina's comment thank
you for your comment Christina so I I
you know I would love to go on the
Progressive
network over there on sxm the problem is
is they might gatekeep this show and
that's the one thing that worries me
the one thing that worries me is
gatekeeping the show I do not want this
show to be gatekeeped I don't want you
to have to pay to watch this show I
don't want you to have to you know go
beyond some pay wall to be able to watch
it it's not what I want I want you to be
able to see it no matter what now I have
the patreon which I want to tell you
we're almost to my 250
um patrons goal we're at 212 I think
right now so we're less than 50 away
from my my patreon goals so that is some
gated content over there we do ask me
anything which I made you um either
tomorrow or Friday I may do an ask me
anything where it's a smaller group of
people you get to ask me anything I
answer every single question in chat it
ain't like uh shoot the [__] where I can
skip questions
uh ask me anything I'll answer every
[__] one of them
um as long as I have time I'll answer
every one of them but we'll go down the
list so there's ask me anything we'll
probably do that tomorrow or Friday and
then we have the Sunday Ranch we have
the patreon parties I sang karaoke at
the last patreon party everyone liked
that someone even said I sounded better
than at uh Two of a Kind than Garth
Brooks I'm gonna have to agree with you
that's right I said it you get over it
and if you don't like it go watch it go
watch it it's on the YouTube channel you
can see the very first patreon party and
we're gonna do more of those every
single month so if you want to check out
what's going on over at patreon go to
patreon.com the Tony Michaels and you
can check out the patreon uh over there
that's the Gated content this show is
not gated and I don't want to ever get
this show I wanted you to have it for
free because I think it's important now
I hope to get some sponsors yeah I'd
love to have [__] people sponsor this
show so I can make some money that would
be nice that would be nice to make a
living doing this and that's and that's
what the patreon is about is it that
really the merch which I have I I have
um a secret to tell you are you guys
listening don't tell anyone this we're
gonna have some new merch tomorrow we're
gonna have some new merch I'm hoping
tomorrow
we're working on the design
and it has to do with a rake
wink
so tune in you're not going to want to
miss at least by the end of the week
we're going to have
um some a new merch design that may or
may not include a rake in there
somewhere so uh be watching for that so
when you guys purchase uh [__] em hats
or merch when you guys go to the patreon
and you join the patreon that's how we
that's how we make a living right that
that's that's how I make a living doing
this
um this show is free I don't I don't
have any AD sponsors all the ads are are
satire and parody at this point of Gabe
Sanchez which you guys really like I
think I'm gonna bring back the um the
boycott binders since they're boycotting
everything I know I said that but
I get a little lost and stuff so but uh
tomorrow tomorrow we will have um um
some new merch a new merch design that
you guys can um that you guys can enjoy
and and that's another great way to
support us and you guys I like the merch
thing because you guys get something
right or the [__] them hats you guys get
something and then in return
um we we get a little change the other
the other way that we make money I want
to be totally transparent here the other
way that we need to um the other way
that we make money
is when you do the Amazon Prime account
with your Twitch account which is kind
of a cool way and the reason why is
because if you have a Prime account it
doesn't cost you anything to link it to
the Twitch account
um and we get some money that way so the
more and that's why I'm saying if we get
more subscribers over on Twitch if we
get more people watching on Twitch if we
get more uh of those subscriptions on
Twitch than um the revenue will come in
and and we'll be able to to sustain the
show because it does cost money I mean
we're here every day so you know we got
to eat and pay for the lights and
electricity and the internet and all
that [__]
it costs money what are you gonna do
it's capitalism I mean some people don't
like it but
it is what it is okay let's get to the
shitless Roundup here I haven't played
this music in a long time so let's start
the countdown
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the show some people are
saying there's some breaking news with
Disney and DeSantis so we'll we'll see
if we can dive into that
um but there's one thing I want to show
you first uh surfing the Tweety tweets
and training Trends someone made this
yesterday Nate made this
ah it's the best meme I've seen in a
long time I don't know who this guy is
carrying the Republican tears but he
seems to be familiar he seems to have a
familiar face I don't know you like that
oh my God I think I put it on Facebook
too so if you if you if you're not if
you're not on Twitter and you want to
see it or spread it around there's a
there's one for that uh let's see here
oh should we go with the religious thing
first uh should I do that first oh my
God you won't believe this these
Christian nationalists so let's do the
whole Bud Light religion thing where
they're they're really upset they're
really upset at Bud Light and it hurts
their religious feels here is a supposed
business owner that owns a chain of
restaurants grills they call it that in
Florida listen to him complain
speaking of marketeers
oh I just uh my my entire my entire uh
Patron base is a bunch of bigots and the
biggest don't want to buy Bud Light I
can't sell them but a lot no more they
just won't buy the queer beer they're
they're scared if they drink beer that
they'll turn gay
get the [__] out of here listen to this
[__] yeah it's been a terrible week it's
been actually a couple of weeks now oh
yeah you don't even know what a week is
yeah experience toughest two weeks
you've ever experienced in your life are
you [__] kidding me listen to me when
I tell you this now this is either this
guy did not own has not owned these
grills for very long because 2020 that
was a [__] for restaurants I don't care
what state you were in okay and then if
you remember all the way back to 2008 to
the Great Recession oh man this is the
toughest two weeks because Dylan
Mulvaney drank a Bud Light on Instagram
you people are [__] stupid okay keep
going with your lies let's hear them
[Music]
why why is it the most difficult period
of your life
you know Anheuser burst they held a
social knife over all of our heads here
and they dropped very irresponsible what
Anheuser-Busch held a social knife over
what the [__] are you talking are you
talking about that you don't agree with
Dylan Mulvaney's identity
because that's not Anheuser-Busch
forcing anything on you you dummies if
anything if anything that is Dylan
Mulvaney forcing Bud Light on his
audience her audience excuse me that's
forcing her on her audience
and again if you watched her video about
Bud Light when she takes the drink of
Bud Light I don't even get the sincere
authentic feeling that she even likes
the taste of Bud Light which most people
don't most most people who drink Bud
Light on a daily basis don't actually
like the taste of it it just gets them
drunk really cheap
the [__] how how doesn't a bar owner
know this but okay social knife hardest
two weeks of your life let's hear what
other [__] you got to sell
it it threw us into turmoil by standing
on our Biblical oh Jesus Christ at odds
with other people that didn't that
didn't take that stance and that brought
us into hell on Earth oh hell on Earth
oh my God here's what he's complaining
about really is that when this happened
there he had he had people in his
restaurant they were really pissed off
right about about the Bud Light
transgender thing the Kid Rock The Kid
Rock video because without the Kid Rock
video this wouldn't even be a thing
[__] it wouldn't without that
stupid
[__] social media theater from Kid
Rock this wouldn't even be a thing and
it's theater because Kid Rock wasn't
even principled enough to stop selling
beer at his bar in Nashville and the
reason why is because when when Bud
Light and Anheuser-Busch goes in
and sells these people beer they're like
yeah we'll give you all these benefits
they're not just selling them beer
they're like yeah we'll give you the
signs we'll pay for your [__] menus
we'll pay for we'll pay for your Taps to
be clean we'll pay for this new
equipment we'll give you a new fridge
I'm serious Anheuser Bush and they're
like but you have to sell this this this
and this beer you have to keep this beer
on tap this beer on tap and this beer on
tap you have to have this beer and this
beer and this drink in bottles
that's what they [__] buy space that
is why this [__] idea that somehow
Anheuser-Busch or Bud Light is going to
go out of business because of these you
people are dumb as dog [__] you have no
clue how [__] the how capitalism
works then you don't know how the Beer
Market works you don't know how bars
work you have no [__] clue how the
restaurant industry works you you don't
know how the convenience store and gas
station industry works you are some
grocery stores you are some dumb sons of
[__]
like the reason why you're still walking
in a bunch of retail stores and there's
big piles of Bud Light and Budweiser and
Anheuser-Busch products everywhere it's
because they bought that space to put
that [__] in
those stores are are forced to put that
that product out front and some might
say well that's why they're still
selling that beer is because they're
forced to how do you think how do you
think [__] consumer decisions work
dummy it's not complicated to understand
that human condition is really simple
and that they have figured out retail
retail science the reason why Budweiser
and the reason why all these Brands want
to be at your eye level height and have
as much [__] space on the Shelf as
possible because that's what you buy
it's not it's not it's not rocket
science it really isn't people want to
make [__] so [__] complicated and
it's not the reason why Bud Light isn't
going anywhere is because it's the
biggest beer brand in the entire nation
it has the biggest market share for a
brand okay the brand itself has to be
now it's it's
lost part of its market share I'll agree
to that because people's
um people's idea for for a product has
changed they're coming out well seltzers
they have different flavored beers they
have different brands but Anheuser Bush
owns most of that [__] and BevMo owns
most of those Brands but Bud Light is
the brand and the reason why is because
Bud Light was the first national brand
that's what everyone is missing in this
whole stupid [__] debate about Bud
Light and if it's going to go bankrupt
is that Bud Light was the first national
brand and that is why it has the largest
market share that's why it's the most
valued brand that's why it's not going
anywhere anytime soon now it's possible
that in the future that brand will fade
and people will change and the market
will change because because the Beer
Market changes over time we're still in
a regional Beer Market
that that's why that's why people out
west drink coolers Gabe Sanchez says he
drinks Coors a lot he's out west up
north they drink Miller Light because
it's in [__] Milwaukee here in the
here in the lower Midwest we drink
[__] Bud Light and Budweiser because
Anheuser-Busch is in St Louis it's not
complicated to understand these things
and it's not complicated to go back and
look at the history of why beer is
regional in the first place because of
ice like literally because of ice to
keep it cold that's the reason why it's
regional you couldn't ship beer 100
[__] years ago from the east coast to
the West Coast it would be skunk by the
time it got there because they couldn't
keep the [__] cold long enough so no one
was going to sell skunk beer in their
establishment so they would buy beer
from the Distributors the makers a beer
close by to them
and what happened over the years as
technology increased I don't know like
refrigerators and [__]
technology changed they were able tap
technology change they were able to
widen their markets
and in in the mid-century when white
beer came about Bud Light became the
biggest [__] National brand and Bud
Light was able to taste the same on the
East Coast as it was on the west coast
they were able to get that consistency
and that's why Bud Light is the biggest
[__] brand that's the reason
and the idea that kid rock in a video of
of a people of rednecks being upset on
social media
it's gonna affect this thing is stupid
and these Christian nationalists are are
way out in front of their skis here on
this Bud Light thing and if if you
didn't look at the CEO statement um from
Anheuser-Busch
then you're not aware that Budweiser nor
um excuse me Bud Light the brand the
marketing team for that brand and
Anheuser-Busch and inbev are scared of
this at all
they're not scared of this if anything
this is giving their brand more air time
than what they could free air time than
what they could dream of and the idea
that these Christian nationalists have
that [__] that that the lgbtq
community are allies of it or people who
don't give a good God damn about who
other people marry
are going to abandon Bud Light
you're yeah come on
um speaking of Christian nationalism
there's another clip I want to show you
I I think we've had this guy in a clip
before at one of the Michael Flynn
events I think this is I I believe so
he looks and feels familiar to me
um his name is Sean I'm not sure how to
say the last name fetch Fitch
I don't know [__] I'm bad with names I
don't read that well okay I'm dyslexic
and I don't [__] you whatever you want
to say but Sean here I think he's been
on a few videos uh with Mike Flynn now
this guy this is uh this is a uh a video
from Oklahoma I believe
I believe that's where he's at in this
clip I'm not sure
um I believe so but he's talking about
Christian nationalism here okay
just listen I listen and believe them
when they tell you what they're saying
listen to this [__] this is crazy [__]
it's all part of the king coming back
that's what we're practicing for
that's why that's why hell hates it that
we're worshiping at every Capitol across
America
that's why we get called where you're
Christian nationalists you want you want
the kingdom to be the government yes did
you hear that yes yes we want the
kingdom to be the government they want a
theocracy
fascist theocracy they're they're
[__] saying it out loud Angie says
David David koresh Vibes yeah you get a
lot of there's a lot with the glasses
and the hair is that what you're saying
Angie he does you're right this does
give you a lot of that that yeah
Davidians type [__] but this guy I'm
telling you it's not just get this guy
it's all these Christian nationalists
they want a fascist theocracy uh so
let's keep listening though it it
doesn't get any better it gets way worse
you want God to come and over take the
government yes there there you go I mean
every single step he makes here he steps
in a big pile of [__] [__] with
people who believe in Liberty
you want Christianity to dictate the
government you want Christianity to
dictate people's lives oh it seems like
that's what we've been saying is the
threat and you're worried about Joe
Biden's age get the [__] out of here
with that nonsense
get the [__] out of here with that
nonsense do you see why the Joe Biden's
age argument is so stupid
because of guys like this
and you think oh well this guy's just
talking in Oklahoma it's no big deal
[__]
if you think they're not saying this all
around the country and every single turn
that they can these fascists aren't
trying to deploy this strategy of white
Christian nationalism inside these
churches to turn out the vote for
fascists you are [__] out of your
mind
you are out of your mind this is one
thing that the fascists and Republicans
do well
they use the churches to deploy their
voters
they've done it for years and now now
they're more overt about their fascist
theocracy that they dream of that
they're creaming in their [__] pants
for listen
you are Christians to be the only ones
yes we do
are you listening to him we you want
Christians to be the only ones yes we do
yeah
out loud
[__] listen
Joe Biden's age is not the threat
if you if you're still like oh Jake is
so smart
tyt gets me oh it's Joe Biden's age
that's gonna cause the problem in the
country you are you are brainwashed this
is the threat
this is the strategy to yell and scream
about I want to show this video to
everyone in the entire country
everyone should see this video I'm
actually disappointed if you look here
this only has 154 000 views
this I you you you you you think I'm
nuts but I'm sure this [__] has
in his contacts on his phone
several United States senators
Republican senators in this phone I
would imagine that there's several
Republican Governors that are in this
guy's Rolodex if you're from the 1990s I
would imagine that there's plenty of
state representatives United States
congressman and congresswoman Republican
mostly white men in this guy's Rolodex
okay
you got it
you got it this guy is telling us what
they're gonna do let's listen
we wouldn't be a disciple of Jesus if we
didn't believe that
we want God to be in control of
everything
they want God to be in control of
everything are you listening
you're not again if you're still [__]
worried
about if Joe Biden is going to be in his
80s or whatever
you're not paying attention to the real
threat
and let me tell you something when you
take your eye off the real threat
is when you're gonna get hurt
and we cannot afford to take our eye off
the threat to our democracy we just
cannot we can't do it
let's keep going
we want Believers to be the ones writing
the Lots yes [__]
it's funny when I meet Christians where
I'm like I don't really I'm not really
I'm like have you read the Great
Commission like yeah this is actually
what we want
guilty
ooh they're guilty they're guilty of of
fascist theocracy
I'm telling you
this is what they [__] want this is
what they're pushing and they're selling
it inside these revivals in these
churches to stoke these people up
that's what they're doing
that's how that's how they're going to
try to win this thing
um you know it brings up a good anytime
uh clip like this comes up a clip a
famous clip of Frank Zappa comes up
now this is from 1986 and I want to show
this
um any of you guys don't know the
musician for example just go look it up
but for example it was in the debate
here and listen to what he says about uh
fascist theocracy
and Christianity we're going to give you
a civics lesson here but I'll tell you
one thing we must not see eye to eye on
the idea of a government that must
forbid things in order to really what is
the government's role you've told me
several times how about National Defense
yeah I consider this National Defense
pal our families are under attack from
people like you with these lyrics John
you don't have people like you with
these lyrics did you hear that so this
guy's leveling attack against Frank
Zappa saying Frank Zappa his lyrics were
of national security threat okay now
um you're going to hear you're going to
hear the defense here but listen to what
Frank Zappa says the actual
threat to National Security right the
words National Security the threat was
wasn't this John you don't have to buy
them
can I make a statement about National
Defense yeah the biggest threat to
America today is not communism it's
moving America toward a fascist
theocracy and everything that's happened
during the Reagan Administration is
steering us right down that pipe Mr zaph
oh Mr Zappa that's one of the funniest
parts of the whole internet oh yeah Mr
Zappa
Frank [__] Mr Zappa is my [__]
father but
of course someone said in the comments
that Frank's is brilliant and Frank it
was brilliant and the reason the reason
why most artists see these things is
because they're a little more clear
about
um what what is and what isn't when
they're not blinded by religion
that's the that's the real Point
sometimes is because Zappa is tuned in
to what is real and what is not because
he's not tied to his religious bias he's
able to see things a little clearly and
I'm not saying that religious people
can't lay aside their religious bias to
make decisions I'm just saying that
might be really [__] hard as an
atheist it's really easy for me I don't
have religious bias at all like I I
don't have any religious bias so I can
lay all that aside that's why I'm like I
don't give a [__] who's [__] who if
as long as it's consensual and you're
adults do whatever you want hell you
have orgies I I actually don't think
polygamy should be outlawed [__] that
[__] if it's consensual polygamy do it
who am I to tell you someone else
what the [__] they can and can't do
it's not my that's not my Liberty to
tell you what you can and can't do or
who you can be or who you can love or
who you can what you can do and where
you can do it it's not my [__]
business
sign my business but listen listen to
The Roundup here
like Frank because there's about a
minute left I mean we're all kidding
aside in this country with the
progressiveness that we are moving
toward a fascist theocracy
you think things like this
smile again
when we were kids you're about my age
maybe 45. well I'm 55. do you think when
I was a kid a thing would permit songs
like that to be sold I mean
permissiveness is the game I mean I mean
you're not you're not really serious if
you're saying we're going toward a
fascist that's right we are wait a
minute and we'll work
one example of a fascist theology
when you have a government that prefers
a certain moral code and derived from a
certain religion and that moral code
turns into legislation to suit one
certain religious point of view and if
that code happens to be very very right
wing almost until the Hun well then you
are an anarchist every form of civil
government is based on some kind of here
it is listen to this Morality In terms
of behavior not in terms of theology
well of course and there it is the
morality is in terms of behavior
character not in theology what your
[__] book says and what your God says
so I'll um I'll retweet this here so
everyone can
follow this and spread this clip around
it's a great clip by for example when
you're trying to find off these
Christian nationalists okay
let's move on
uh speaking of um let's see
let's see let's see let's see I thought
I had another yeah
um okay speaking of Christian
nationalists here's a clip from um uh
Matt gatz and Marjorie Taylor green and
they're really upset let's listen and
one of the platforms you and I have used
extensively is the Tucker Carlson
tonight program that sadly is no more on
Fox
[Music]
oh they're crying about the 8 P.M hour
listen there's still an 8 P.M hour
there's still an 8 PM hour it's just not
the white supremacist Tucker Carlson
that will be hosting it permanently it
might be at some other white supremacist
that is posting in the [__] out of here
you [__] whining little [__]
they're such they're such [__] oh God
such nincomputin Nazis crying about
Tucker Carlson the [__] out of here um
here's a good one
right wing cop had this this is
hilarious look at this
um so this is this this is what some on
the right are saying and this looks like
it's on Facebook
um you know this this lady writes Tucker
Oh and then someone down here says yes
and it was Biden who called and told
them to be fired
what uh right when KO points out Biden
famous for being the CEO of Fox News
this is really weird stuff where they're
like Joe Biden is is he's an idiot and
he's not even control of his own
faculties but he's calling and demanding
Fox News fire attacker Carlson all of a
sudden and then like you know what sure
that's cool we'll do that
what the [__]
it's ridiculous they're boneheads what
are you gonna do they're [__]
moanheads
[Music]
let's see
um
I thought I had another clip here of
ah boneheads I want to show you this you
know what speaking of boneheads here you
go here you go we'll talk about it more
here here it is here it is
here's your [__] tyt clip
uh maybe they'll use the copyright
feature on YouTube to search this and
he'll finally see this I don't know
probably not but let's let's listen I'm
gonna I'm gonna show you what he's
saying in the dumb stupid [__] he's
saying and why if you're listening to
this garbage
you're listening to garbage number one
reason I'm worried about buying this
because I think he's gonna lose right
oh
the number one reason why is he thinks
he's gonna lose
he has no evidence there's no evidence
he has none not a shred of data or facts
or anything that could prove that Joe
Biden's gonna lose I mean he's like oh
36 percent of
Propel anywhere to tell you what you
want to to frame up your narrative
[__] crazy [__]
but that ain't that doesn't make it
truth let's keep listening
and but whenever you say it on TV or in
the Press at all the swarm of locusts of
DNC Consultants attack and they're like
could win what okay so you know my
stance here and you know I'm not some
[__] DNC consultant I don't I mean
I'll be completely transparent I've
never been paid anything from the DNC I
don't get daily phone calls from Jamie
Harrison
but okay whatever whatever Jank whatever
you want whatever you want listen
I'm not crying about Joe Biden being the
only one winning I'm giving you the
[__] truth
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter if I
or you or anyone else
wants Joe Biden two two or two not be
the nominee we elected him as the
Democratic president in 2020 okay that's
what we did he is the sitting United
States president in the Democratic party
and he gets to decide if he's gonna run
he has decided that it is clear he has
decided we knew he was going to do this
but it's clear he's decided this
yesterday he's announced this it's
official
and he will be the nominee there will
not be debates there won't be anyone to
debate him and the reason why is because
he's the incumbent he will he will get
all every single one of the super
delegates every [__] one of them
every single one of them will be given
to Joe Biden that is how the Democratic
primary
for a [__] incumbent Democratic
president works if you go back to 2012
that's exactly how it worked with Obama
do you remember Obama ever standing on
stage and debating someone
in 2012 do you remember that
anybody
anybody what about Bill Clinton do you
remember Bill Clinton
being challenged standing on stage
debating anybody
1996 do you remember that
now
there's a reason there's a [__]
reason it's not complicated it's not
complicated for him to understand this
he knows this he's lying to you he's
[__] lying Jank is a [__] liar
he's a grifter that's what he is let's
listen
you're you're playing with fire you're
playing with all of our Lives you're
playing with democracy he wanted 36 uh
last time around he could easily be a 36
percent and win this time around you
guys almost flew it the last time you
definitely blew at the time before
listen [__] the last time in the
time before you wanted Bernie Sanders
you [__] idiot he was pimping for
Bernie Sanders
and I I don't I don't know if you
remember the delegate Counts from the
DNC in 2016 and 2020. I don't know if
you remember that but some of this
burning or bust [__]
was all wise too that they were selling
and Jake I don't want to pull up the
clip where you say Barack Obama's a
republican again I really don't but I I
mean I could do it if you want me to
if you want me to um someone says I
wanted Bernie yeah absolutely I mean My
My First Choice my first choice
in in the 2020 primary now I knew Biden
was going to win I was I was steeped in
the reality that Biden was going to win
uh I had relatives that were hardcore
Bernie and I was trying to tell them hey
Biden's gonna win it ain't gonna be
Bernie I I really wanted to see Pete
Buda judge be a competitor in that race
because it to me
um some people like and hate Pete
bootage but I think the Youth of people
to judge maybe the future of the party
eventually I don't know we'll see we'll
find out we'll see what comes
um with either Gavin Newsom or Pete Buda
judge or some of these other rising
stars and we've got a lot of rising
stars in the Democratic party a lot of
them are coming a lot of them
there's gonna be a lot
but right now that doesn't that that's
not how it works so just because you
want something doesn't mean you're gonna
get it that's how that's how democracy
works that's how compromise works that's
why liberalism is so difficult it it is
the it is the beacon of strength because
it is difficult to live inside that
reality of liberalism authoritarianism
is easy okay authoritarianism to decide
that you're just going to sign your
entire life away to one person and one
person with the stroke of the pen can
either give you something or take it
away that's a really easy idea
that's an easy reality to to to try to
deal with when when you're in this Human
Condition
but when you're in the fight for
democracy and the fight for liberty and
rights and freedoms equity and equality
it's going to be difficult and in a
difficult fight for that you're gonna be
disappointed
at some point and who is your who is
your elected officials
that's that's just the pure simple fact
of it you're not going to love every
single elected official that's going to
be a part of the party that you're in or
the party that you prefer it's just not
gonna happen
and and what what this [__] idiot's
trying to sell to his audience is
perfection
and that's not what what you should
strive for especially in this moment in
history is perfection we we are never
going to achieve perfection in our
democracy we're not not for every single
person
because our democracy is built of
individuals that are our Collective
right
so every individual isn't going to be
completely happy
with the situation in this country and
honestly I want a lot of individuals to
be really upset about 10 to 12 percent
of the individuals in this country that
are Christian nationalists I definitely
want them to be [__] upset about
their elected officials I want them to
be really upset about their elected
officials because if Christian
nationalists in this country are
completely upset about all their elected
officials state and federal level then
we're doing something right for
democracy folks
the way it is so [__] this game but
let's let's continue with this little
whining he's such a little whiny [__]
it's the same clowns and now we're gonna
have two guys that are above 76 years
old they're both going to be hiding in
their basements listen you [__] this
[__] bonehead he was pushing for
Bernie Sanders
he was pushing for Bernie Sanders in
2020 and if Bernie would have won the
primary and would have won the
presidency guess who this [__]
would be cheering
do you think do you think do you think
jankier would be saying oh Bernie's too
old he's above 76 he's way too old to be
he wouldn't be saying that [__] come on
gank Jank I I think it's Jank it's
spelled c-e-n-t some people say I'm I
think I'm saying Jake but I'm not saying
Jake I'm a [__] hillbilly so I'm
saying Jank and I think that's how he
pronounced it and I'm probably
I'm probably not saying it correctly
some people think you say it's sync but
it isn't Sync It's [__] and and I'm
probably again I'm probably pronouncing
it [__] wrong but
do you think I give a [__] no okay let's
let's listen right neither one is gonna
debate this is the worst election ever
no okay so neither one of them is gonna
debate so he's making the call that
neither Trump nor Biden is going to
debate which Trump will not debate Trump
is the one who has to debate he's in the
[__] primary
in a Republican primary with people
he's in a Republican primary of people
so if he chooses not to debate then
that's his choice there's not going to
be anyone for Joe Biden to debate you
have to debate to gain delegates
you [__] bonehead
why in the why in the [__] doesn't he
understand this
that the only time you need to have a
debate is when the delegates are at odds
and generally speaking in a Democratic
primary the reason why delegates would
be at odds is because there's no
incumbent
when there is an incumbent the delegates
aren't at odds they're not the Schubert
delegates are not going to be at odds in
these states and they're going to choose
Joe Biden which means Joe Biden is the
nominee which means there's no reason
for the Democratic National Committee to
hold the baits when Joe Biden is going
to secure the nomination without doing
anything it's really stupid stuff it's
really dumb and really honestly if we
want to ruin Democratic candidates in
the Futures careers like let's say
let's say Pete bootage I mean if we're
going to talk about [__] fantasy Jank
let's say Pete Buddha judge and Gavin
Newsom decide to get in this race right
let's just say let's say Kamala Harris
said I'm not going to run on the ticket
with you I'm going to run against you
Joe Biden because I think I should be
president whatever whoever the [__] you
want to have on this ticket whoever you
want to Elizabeth Warren Bernie Sanders
whatever your [__] fantasies are and
your your absolute delusion is fine
let's go with that
let's go with that why in the [__] would
we as a party as the pro-democracy
Coalition want these people to get up on
stage and damage each other in a primary
where the super delegates are going to
pick Joe Biden anyways it would be
worthless it would be absolute theater
but that's what he wants he wants the
theater right he wants people to damage
Biden he doesn't like Biden he wants
people to damage him
it's not [__] stupid
let's keep let's finish it up here with
this idiot no one wants either one of
the candidates our democracies and
shambles and they force the two
literally the two most unpopular
politicians in the country as our only
two choices that's not that's not who is
they see what he's doing they they they
they they they they they they they we We
the People the Democrats in the primary
in 2020 you dumb [__] chose Joe
Biden that's who they is
saying they that's the voters in the
Democratic primary you've you [__]
rube
the voters chose Joe Biden in 2020 to be
the nominee that's what happened not not
some [__] Council somewhere not some
[__] secret deep State cabal you
bonehead The Establishment chose them
yeah the Democratic party chose their
nominee
if you don't like the party go start
your own good luck with that
Go Do Your Own Thing stop trying to
dictate what the Democrats want to have
in their [__] establishment which is
their party
he knows this that's the thing that
pisses me off the most is he knows this
and he sells these lies to his [__]
audience that's what pisses me off the
most and it's all it's all the keep them
[__] brainwashed and and watching
all of it
is and it's all a grift
and it's what it is
I'm sorry whatever you want to say I
don't give a [__] and you come at me
with the tyt but I'm Gonna Keep
hammering them I don't give a [__]
and the reason why is because he's
trying to pin Democrats up in this
argument
I'm telling you he's trying to pin
Democrats up in this argument that
they're like they try to look like
they're Biden simps I don't need to be a
Biden simp to understand the process I
don't need I don't need to long for Joe
Biden to be my president to understand
what the [__] is reality and what isn't
listen he's selling [__] to his
audience
and again Jank I don't want to keep
pulling up the clip or you say Barack
Obama was a republican but I'll do it if
I have to I'll do it which I mean I
don't know I mean you can say what you
want about the clip but it obviously
shows that that tyt and Jank have no
[__] have no [__] clue what
they're talking about when back in
[__] 2000 I think it was 2014 is when
he said
2014 I believe it is it's when he said
Barack Obama
is a republican so he can [__] off all
the way oh let's see you know what else
can [__] off Donald Trump let's get to
the E Gene Carroll thing here real quick
um agent Carroll was on the stand this
morning I don't know if she's still on
or what has transpired um I'm sure I'll
have more news about this tomorrow
because it's kind of going on as we were
uh Donald Trump uh Amy vanderpol Says
Donald Trump can't even be bothered to
attend his own rape and defamation trial
but he can pop off some derogatory
nonsense about aging care right before
she's about to testify here's what he
was saying this morning they got caught
lying Miss Berg off Goodman cases
Finance blah blah blah blah and he went
on and on and on to disparage the
witness in the case and the defendant in
the case
um on fraud social apparently this
morning the judge was not happy about
these posts and Donald Trump honestly
keep posting man these posts are going
to get you in more and more hot water in
the courts and with judges so keep going
man eat rake let them eat rake let them
eat rake I'm not even gonna read the
comments because it's [__] disgusting
number one and number two he's [__]
delusional
um so
there's a there's some news on the E
Gene uh Carol she did she was on the
stand she was going to testify
um let me read you I think I think there
was a someone had a quote uh from her
Victor had it here uh this is a quote
Victor has a quote on Twitter here he
says oh damn EG Carol has taken the
stand just now and her first sentence
was quote I'm here because Donald Trump
raped me unquote end quote this is what
bravery courage is standing up for
rapist and the bully looks like Eugene
Caro is a hero and we should be so
grateful to Hamburger so that was
Victor's uh tweet this morning about her
first statements which were I'm here
because Donald Trump raped me was e Gene
Carroll's opening statement on the stand
okay um
there's some news
um here about Ivanka
and so I want to get to that real quick
I want to tell you and these are spaces
that we're going to be watching Ivanka
has hired her own lawyer instead of
sharing Eric and Don Juniors also her
new lawyer is Epstein's old lawyer Mary
Trump always said she'd roll first so it
looks like uh in an effort of the fraud
suit it looks like Eric and Don are
holding on to an attorney and Ivanka
ditches that attorney possibly in an
effort to split uh her view of that of
that legal liability which kind of
indicates that she might be flipping at
least protecting herself
okay now here's a great clip by AOC uh
this morning in a hearing I want to show
you this now here's AOC listen to her
about taxes and the Republicans 10 years
so instead of looking at climate and
instead of looking at cuts to health
care we should examine why
our colleagues in the Republican party
is so invested in protecting the
wealthiest people in this society and
would rather attack health care and
services for our veterans than repealing
tax cuts for yacht owners and private
jets and with that I yield my I yield my
time and there you go there you go so
AOC they're giving her thoughts on what
the budget measures are of course
um this morning Kevin McCarthy can't
bring a vote for his budget to to
increase the debt ceiling and save the
American economy their goal is to tank
it by the way they really want the
economy to think and that's important to
them here's another Republican talking
about the budget this morning this is
really [__] weird you would think
he's talking about mass shootings or
shootings in elementary schools listen
to Jody
Arrington Arrington I don't know where
this guy's from he's a he's a Rube but
let's listen people lastly this one and
it's
I get emotional about it
so but because it's real this is real
okay he's from Texas apparently and he's
talking because he's the budget
committee chair this [__] is
he's getting emotional about the the
budget listen to what he says about the
budget
um
the most vulnerable group in America in
my mind and there are lots of vulnerable
groups and we have to be responsible
and we have to prioritize that's what
this is about prioritizing but it's also
about protecting the future as we
prioritize and our children's future
I think the most vulnerable vulnerable
group in America are the children that
have no place in this town no lobbyists
to speak of that I know Jesus Christ no
seed around the table it feels like
and they're going to inherit 31 trillion
dollars in debt and Counting
this guy is super concerned about
children inheriting debt not taking
bullets in elementary schools he's quite
okay with that he's fantastically okay
he's fantastically okay with the
children taking fire in elementary
schools he just
he's concerned they don't have lobbyists
because everyone else has lobbyists he's
noticed that he definitely noticed the
lobbyist apparently
just didn't notice that the children
didn't have them he [__] [__] me this
is a crazy [__] no boy we're coming to
the end of the show I apologize but I do
have one more thing I want to show you
it doesn't have to do with politics
well I guess I could probably turn it
into politics because it has to do with
AI and AI generated commercials
this is the [__] that nightmare is made
of folks
but it's [__] hilarious
oh my God it is hilarious
okay so you guys have heard of
artificial intelligence you guys know
that AI generated pictures have been
happening all the internet has been
making the buzz some internet
um videos I've been going around
um
and AI is a unique technology because
it's going to change
um how we view reality right and what I
mean by that is that you're gonna have
to question and now this is what I think
is the good result of AI okay this is
the good result of AI is that we as as
humans
are now going to have to question
everything we see digitally
is if it's real or not that's not a bad
thing skepticism is not a bad thing the
problem comes when you use
um these pieces of material that you
should be skeptical of
and your evidence of the truth right so
that's the problem with that that's the
balancing act that we're gonna have to
have so AI is literally in its infancy
um and it is going to and the internet
is too but I actually believe in the
next two decades um AI is going to bring
us to a better spot
as the digital age continues here and
the reason why is because we're going to
have to be more Vigilant about it and
and and I I really think and what I mean
is as individuals we're gonna have to be
more Vigilant about what we're what
we're seeing and what what is real and
what is reality
and it's gonna be okay to live
in a era where digital doesn't have to
be
um
the truth the digital reality that
you're living doesn't have to be the
truth but you have to have truth inside
your actual real life reality right and
and this is a great example of it it's
it's
um
it's again the things that nightmares
are made of that's what I tweeted about
this but this is a totally AI generated
Pizza commercial it feels like it's from
the 1990s watch this this is [__]
hilarious
are you ready for best pizza of life
bring friends down to pepperoni hugspot
our chefs make pizza with heart and
Special Touch cheese pepperoni vegetable
and more secret things secret things
need delivery pizzas come fast knock
knock who's there
eat pepperoni Hot Spot Pizza you're
telling me say thank you your mouth
today
pepperoni Hot Spot it's like family but
with more oh it's like family but with
more cheese are you kidding me this is
hilarious this is funny as [__] now I'll
tell you again
it doesn't it you know when they're
eating the pizza and you can tell it's
really it's really [__] it's not real
right you can tell it's not real
but just imagine just months ago and
just a year ago what this would have
looked like in AI it would have been
much worse it would have been as well
produced now it's funny now
um but there are going to be a lot of AI
generated things
um a lot of people are trying to use
chat GPT to push narratives uh to get
chat GPT and it's it's a it's a written
form of AI
um so again I'm not I'm not going to say
that there's not going to be a lot of
learning curve here with AI there
definitely is but in the long run in the
long run anytime the human race has come
up against something that is um that is
a threat to us uh or or to our pursuit
of Liberty and happiness
um we have met it and we have been a
good match for it
um and the internet is new and this AI
is definitely brand spanking new and
Chris's AI is very dangerous yes it is
very dangerous the internet's very
dangerous we we know that social media
is very dangerous and that's why I say
we need to be more Vigilant as
individuals and I think AI is going to
keep us on our toes and what I mean by
that is that when you see something
you're going to question whether it's re
or not which I think is a place when we
get to where the majority of people
consuming stuff on the internet are
asking themselves every time they see
something is this real that's the first
thing you ask yourself is is this real
and if that's the first thing we're
asking ourselves I think we're going to
be in a much better position to be quite
honest with you um we're going to be
back to a position in a timeline where
reality matters and the the greatest
news I have for you is Gen Z that
generation when they see something on
the Internet that is the first thing
they think I know it sounds crazy but my
son is part of gen Z
and when when I show him something
almost every time his reaction is is
that real and that can't be real maybe
that's real Is that real and that I'm
telling you that is the mindset that we
need for reality to come back
um to be popular again
make reality popular again make reality
great again I don't know maybe we can
make some hats with that with that
saying on it everybody holy [__] it's
been two hours are you kidding me it's
been two hours
and it was just me today and I didn't I
didn't quit didn't stop didn't have one
pause not one I got some great news for
you I'm hoping that tomorrow we'll have
some new merch we got a new merch design
again it may or may not have to do with
a rake
if you're catching my drift
um so be looking for that either
tomorrow or Friday for the new merch
you're going to be able to go to store
not meet tonymichaels.com but go check
it out over there right now we got some
great
um we got some great merch over there we
got Ron DeSantis can go [__] himself
apparently there's a Disney DeSantis uh
more update in the feud today so go
check out that Rhonda Santos can go [__]
himself merch at store.d Tony
michaels.com also go visit at D Tony
michaels.com and click the patreon link
or go to patreon.com the Tony Michaels
in the next couple days I'm gonna do an
ask me anything and of course this
weekend on Sunday I'm gonna do the
Sunday rant which is um exclusive
content over on patreon so go to
patreon.com the Tony Michaels or just go
to thetonymichaels.com all the links are
there for the store for the patreon for
the YouTube channel don't forget to
subscribe to the YouTube channel don't
forget to follow us on Twitter those
links are all over there download every
single episode on Apple's phone to buy
Google those links are over there as
well the Facebook link is over there on
the Tony Michaels you can follow us at
the Tony Michaels and of course the
twitch link is over there and again if
you have an Amazon Prime account a great
way
to help monetize the show and give us
money without it costing you a thing if
you have an Amazon Prime account you can
link it to your Twitch account give us
your one free subscription that you get
and make sure to renew it every single
month let's see if we had news yes we
had some new resubscribers uh delarius
has been two months they resubscribed
this morning for two months Time band it
Jared Our Time Bandit Jared excuse me
Time Bandit Jared uh subscribe for three
months this morning so thank you for
that thank you for re-subscribing over
on Twitch again just remember on Twitch
you have to resubscribe every month and
all you Chatters on Twitch when you see
people coming in remind them of that too
if you if you would for me I love the uh
the the twitch chat is a different chat
I don't know if you know that if you
like the YouTube chat you might you
might like the twitch chat it's a little
different over there
it's a little different some people like
the twitch some people like the app
better so go check it out we're trying
to get to um a thousand followers over
there we're almost to 900 so we're just
over a hundred
from getting to a thousand uh speaking
of goals I also have a goal of 250 on
patreon I'm at 212 now so if you'll help
me out over there that would be
fantastic we're gonna be here tomorrow
of course every single weekday noon
Eastern 11 Central nine Pacific right
here on YouTube Twitter and twitch
same time same place
Surfside [__]
you've been listening listen to Tony
Michael's podcast in your face
commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow toning
on social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[__] em
[Music]
Murphy's mealborn headass Beacon